wer weiß schon heute
morgen sind jeden tag
er weiß schon heute morgen sind wir mal
wieder das neu beginnt
so meine damen und herren wir sind nun
auch den münchner oktoberfest
münchnerisch ist natürlich die tracht
man kann den touristen von den
eigentlichen bayern nicht mehr wirklich
unterscheiden
darum zeige ich euch jetzt ein paar
tricks wie man sie erkennen kann
erstens die lederhose sie muss dreckig
und speckig sein weil man wäscht sich
die hände an der lederhosen ab wenn man
seinen gästen
zweitens dürfen diese leute nichts
aufgebaut sein sondern müssen aufgenäht
sein und dann das wichtigste man darf
keine turnschuhe zu der nieder hosen
sagen hier vorne gleich zum beispiel
immer gleichen tourist hier seine
sportschuhe mit lederhose kombiniert
geht gar nichts
man bestellt eine massige das starkbier
also zehn euro gibt man natürlich für
einen liter bier aber man zahlt ja auch
fürs handy
also was man auf jeden fall machen muss
weil man auf diese geht dank medizin lvd
lukas
so natürlich so wenn du hier auf dem
oktoberfest auch irgendwie ein fest
schwindel mitnehmen möchtest musst du
dich nur hau den lukas spielen sondern
muss natürlich auch ein präsent kaufen
in münchen ganz traditionell ein herzl
dasteht irgendwas drauf wie du bist mein
sport saal und andere lustige bayerische
setzte aber es gibt nur einen wirklich
bayerischen satz der alles sagt und der
heißt im aktiv das wars vom oktoberfest
gleicht dem wir uns nächstes jahr oder
nicht vergessen